welcome back to CBS this morning it's
been nearly three months since the first
coronavirus case was detected in the
u.s. Yale as the pandemic has grown
medical professionals have quickly
experienced shortages of the critical
supplies that they need and they're
talking about a to Anthony one emergency
room nurse at Jacobi Medical Center in
the Bronx in New York spoke to 60
minutes Bill Whitaker last night
this nurse said it's unacceptable for
the richest country in the world to run
out of medical equipment and I know it's
a pandemic and we it's just really hard
for us just to accept the fact that this
is the best that we can do I wouldn't
wish this upon anybody we're running out
of supplies that it's not just the PPE
and ventilators we're running out of IV
pumps we're running out of stuff that we
never ran out of before yeah it doesn't
make us sound like a global superpower
and it's another country China that
produces more personal protection
equipment or PPE than anyone else in the
world and the Chinese government now
says it will impose tougher restrictions
on PPE before it's shipped out of the
country other governments private
companies and nonprofits plus profiteers
are competing for those critical medical
supplies chief investigative
correspondent Jim Axelrod shows us how
buyers in the United States are
struggling to get what they need we need
the masks the respirators all the gowns
the gloves
Aubrey Layne is Virginia's finance
secretary responsible for purchasing his
state supply of PPE or personal
protective equipment right now Jim we're
buying whatever we can get it's not
enough if the surge hits the way we
anticipate it to in the next two to
three weeks where are you looking the
easy answer is we're looking everywhere
most of these are sourced overseas
particularly out of China but in dealing
with China its buyer beware great grades
totally a new missions here American
distributors tell CBS News PPE factories
are popping up overnight some faking US
government approvals by using templates
like this one we've got to make sure
or they are real and credible vendors
that once excelled churning out
everything from cheap watches and
children's toys are now Hawking highly
coveted n95 masks we've had one case
where we're up with a very reputable
supplier and yet when it got ready to
ship the Chinese government decided to
for better take possession of the goods
because they want them to go somewhere
else
despite widespread shortages the US has
refused to launch a national procurement
effort the federal government's not
supposed to be out there buying vast
amounts of items and then shipping you
know we're not a shipping clerk Lane
says that's a problem there's no really
overall coordinated federal strategy for
managing that so we've been told pretty
much it's fed for yourselves Lane says
he's bidding for Chinese product against
other states some of the suppliers know
this and so they'll call us up and say
you got to make a decision pretty
quickly or it's gonna go to someone else
suppliers are demanding payment up front
dealing with taxpayer money Lane says he
needs to make sure he's not being ripped
off and we're not talking about a couple
of hundred bucks we're spending here are
we know we're talking in the millions of
dollars typically for shipments I give
each buyer 15 minutes China based
consultant clyde greenwood represents
three local manufacturers that he says
sell medical supplies mostly to foreign
governments there is a massive world
demand and they are just not going to
wait for people to did they're around
competing buyers he says are not holding
back as they're going up to factories
with truckloads of cash and taking the
entire production earlier this month a
shipment of 80,000 masks arrived at this
hard-hit hospital in northern New Jersey
the delivery didn't come courtesy of the
State Health Department but from a
nonprofit called Helena the group is
buying up PPE at inflated costs and
selling it back to hospitals at its
normal price Henry Elka's he's one of
the founders sometimes within an hour
the purchases would actually get sniped
away by other parties maybe add a zero
to the price and then sell it to
hospitals later or in some cases even
even hold the product how much price
gouging is going on
maths that should be under $1 go to $5
it hurts because it's it's business in
some cases and profit motive trumping
real lives Elka says he's one of many
private donors filling the gap where
governments have fallen short this is
not a project we should be doing this
should be something that is being taken
care of by the government
Virginia's finance secretary aubrey lane
agrees the feds need to step up because
he's worried about who he's dealing with
you don't really know when the orders
will be filled or if the orders will be
filled hopefully it's more a matter of
when and not if but even that will what
we won't know until the actual planes
get here or the cargo gets here a US
official tells CBS News that while the
federal government is not buying PPE
directly from China FEMA is helping
private companies fly orders of masks
and gloves and gowns from China to
hotspots in the United States now
another source tells CBS News that most
Chinese factories that manufacture PPE
will not be taking any new orders until
May at the earliest tony and of course
the stakes couldn't be any higher Jim
Axelrod fourth Jim thank you very much